et pour en parler nous sommes avec
stéphane barennes ce qui est rédacteur
en chef des héros à spacium bonjour
stéphane merci d'être avec nous sur la
tvh france alors que pensez-vous des
annonces faites par bruno le maire sont
elles suffisantes pour aider le secteur
aéronautique alors figurez vous que j'ai
posé la question tout à l'heure à eric
trappier le patron du gifas donc le
l'organisation qui regroupe l'industrie
française de l'aéronautique et de
l'espace est lui même n'en étaient
réduits cadets espoirs
une chose est sûre c'est que sans ce
plan
l'industrie serait vraiment en piteuse
situation parce que la crise du coc vide
a fait extrêmement mal mais ce qu'on
oublie c'est que c'est la deuxième crise
qui vient frapper le secteur notamment
pour le domaine de la sous-traitance
parce que l'an dernier les industriels
français qui travaillent donc sûrement
provoque pour airbus mais aussi pour
boeing ont dû subir l'arrêt de deux vols
et de livraison du 737 max qui était
donc le concurrent des a320 pour lequel
beaucoup d'entreprises françaises
travaillent cet avion a connu deux
crashs fin 2018 début 2019 et donc est
atteint de deux vols depuis mars 2019 ce
qui a causé d'énormes problèmes pour
toutes les entreprises qui travaillaient
pour lui et qu'il est donc livré des
moteurs des trains d'atterrissage des
cabines et toutes ses activités
mais justement elisabeth borrel a
souligné la france est l'un des seuls
pays à pouvoir à fabriquer un avion de a
à z on imagine que les sous traitants
ont beaucoup souffert de cette crise
vous venez de le dire mais est-ce qu'il
n'est pas trop tard pour eux
alors les grands donneurs d'ordres ont
beaucoup travaillé à soutenir leurs sous
traitants ce jusqu'à présent le beaucoup
de monde dans l'industrie arrêt aussi
comment dire il ya eu une centaine de
milliers de l'employé qui ont profité du
chômage partiel
donc ce plan arrive à point nommé pour
prendre le relais et il faut bien voir
que ce n'est pas juste une aide
ce plan est là pour demander quelque
chose à l'industrie en échange de son
soutien
donc ça peut être des livraisons
d'appareils
en avance de phase ça peut être il ya un
milliard et demi pour du développement
envers de l'avion moins carboné pour
accélérer la transition vers des
appareils qui permettrait moins de gaz à
effet de serre donc en fait ça arrive au
bon moment
vous vous n'êtes vous venez de l'évoquer
injustement le l'avion l'avion vers le
but est de sauver l'avion vers zéro
émission de co2 attendu pour 2035 mais
ce que la crise va pas contrarier ses
plans ou en tout cas les retarder en
fait la crise permet de restructurer le
le secteur bon vous le montrez un a380
l'a380 devait continuer à être produit
jusque vers 2022
maintenant la chaîne est arrêtée elle ne
reprendra pas ses appareils vont quitter
notre notre ciel ce bon certains vont le
regretter mais donc on va vers une
transition vers d'autres types
d'appareils
la demande va changer il y aura moins de
gros long courriers plus de deux
monocouloirs plus de deux monocouloirs à
long rayon d'action ce qui tombe bien
c'est un domaine où airbus a beaucoup
investi et à comment dire à des produits
à présenter alors que en face boeing est
plutôt façon claire à la ramasse donc il
y a une opportunité quelque part grâce à
cette crise alors cette opportunité va
se confirmer dans les prochains mois
mais qui qui va le plus souffrir parce
que on imagine que tu vas y avoir de la
souffrance quand même vis-à-vis de cette
crise sanitaire est ce que ce sont les
entreprises où les salariés finalement
alors les entreprises vont tout faire
pour qu'il n'y ait pas de licenciements
secs car c'est un secteur qui est très
particulier c'est torriero nautique
il n'y a pas d'emplois non qualifiés
donc il y a une énorme expertise à
conserver les employés font la valeur
des entreprises
donc il va y avoir beaucoup d'efforts
pour éviter que ses équipes se disperse
que ses équipes sent l'ail ce n'est pas
le cas dans d'autres pays
hier j'étais en train de travailler sur
un article sur ce qui se passe au québec
où l'industrie est dans un état
absolument désastreux
ici l'idée c'est de conserver au maximum
les équipes donc éventuellement de que
les réductions d'emplois se fasse sur
les départs en retraite de manière à ce
que les compétences acquises ne soit pas
perdu parce que pour les renouveler pour
les produire et installer si on ne
devait les pères d'aujourd'hui il
faudrait compter une génération ce qui
serait dramatique
merci beaucoup stéphane barennes ski
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le rédacteur en
chef d'aero à spacium